c'est en 2009 que le projet de service
par bus le SRB Pie-IX a été annoncé par
l'ancien maire de Montréal Gérald
Tremblay en 2015 des équipes ont été
mobilisées pour la conception du projet
en 2018 les travaux se sont amorcés
et 14 ans et 523 millions de dollars
plus tard le srbi P9 voit enfin le jour
dès lundi les usagers du transport en
commun pourront circuler entre le
boulevard Saint-Martin à Laval jusqu'à
l'avenue Pierre de Coubertin à Montréal
au quotidien on parle souvent des fois
de projets qui pour lesquels il y a des
obstacles des embûches des choses qui
sont plus corsées en matière de projets
d'infrastructure mais là aujourd'hui on
a une bonne nouvelle on fait encourager
les gens apprendre le transport
collectif parce que la voiture solo
n'est plus soutenable avec ou sans
travaux dans le pont tunnel avec les
embouteillages attendus ou pompidel la
fontaine le développement de cette taxe
routier Nord Sud pour améliorer le flux
de circulation ça peut désengorger un
petit peu mais bon parce que les gens
qui vont prendre l'autobus Pie-IX
normalement c'est pour aller travailler
au centre-ville la ligne Express 439
devrait passer à un intervalle de 4 à 10
minutes pour un usager qui ferait la
route entre Henri Bourassa et le métro
Pie-IX le temps de parcours dimin permet
de 10 à 15 minutes sans le SRB ce même
trajet prend en moyenne 40 minutes alors
on se trouve à bord du SRV Pie-IX donc
c'est un premier test pour la ligne
Express 439 ici à Montréal et on
s'attend à ce que le trajet soit 30 %
plus rapide qu'à l'origine la
construction de la voie aura pris un peu
plus de 3 ans une éternité pour certains
commerçants qui racontent avoir frôlé la
faillite presque la faillite mais ils
ont fait une bonne chose aussi à la fin
qu'est-ce qui m'a sauvé c'est qu'ils ont
donné une petite récompense
Montréal Nord dit bien accueillir
l'entrée en fonction du SRB jusqu'à 70
000 usagers pourraient en bénéficier
selon les estimations de la STM ici
Gabriel prout Radio-Canada Montréal